come out thanos i know you're hiding in
there
thanos was but a minor nuisance compared
to me child
i am the mcu's greatest enemy galactus
mephisto the one below all no
corporate expectations
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that's only loosely been about
major motion pictures ever since the
global pandemic thrust
trolls world tour into a default oscar
nod but i gotta say there is
some good news to all of this downtime
all the hours that i used to spend in
theaters every week looking for juicy
theorizable details can now be spent
combing over the enormous backlog of
comic books that have been piling up
over the last few years
as loyal fans know some of my best
predictions have come from comic book
plot lines
marvel likes to test out ideas for the
mcu in their comics first and in secret
empire number seven natasha makes the
ultimate sacrifice but what's important
here is that black widow has shown that
she's willing to sacrifice herself to
stop the worst possible timelines from
playing out but today i'm going deeper
way way deeper thanks to a shake-up in
the marvel leadership kevin feige
formerly the head marvel movie guy is
now just the head
marvel guy guy i.e he is now the
creative director in charge
of everything that marvel legally
controls that ranges from the movies
of course but also the tv shows and also
now
the comic books with unprecedented power
comes unprecedented responsibility
feige is taking control of marvel at its
peak and with the most ambitious
crossover event in history already
behind him a lot of fans are wondering
where it all goes next well loyal
theorists i'm here today to posit that
feige is planning something
absolutely massive going forward a
crossover event to make end game and
into the spider-verse seem like small
potatoes just like the infinity war saga
was ultimately building to a climactic
battle against thanos i'm now convinced
that kevin feige is building this next
story arc into a battle that'll merge
the marvel multiverse first it needs to
be established that marvel has
something of a loosely connected
multiverse going there's a long history
of numbering universes in marvel
especially in the comics with the
universe numbered 616 being the primary
marvel universe say what you will about
dc's movies but at the very least they
have the common decency to start with
universe 1.
also just to make matters even more
confusing rather than calling it
universe 616 as would make total sense
it almost
always is designated by earth numbers
meaning that even if you're talking
about out in space activities you're
still referring to the whole thing as
the earth 616 continuity
but even more more confusingly earth 616
is part of a multiverse that has been
reborn multiple times
in total there have been seven
multiverse renewals during the entire
history of the marvel multiverse where
an
old multiverse completely dies out only
to be replaced by a new one in other
words marvel comics exist
in a multi multiverse so earth 616
is the main timeline but there are
plenty of other fun little offshoots
plenty of others
earth 90214 is marvel noir where
daredevil
iron man spider-man and the x-men get
dropped into the 1920s for some good
old-fashioned timey wimey antics earth
is the universal id for the marvel anime
yeah the marvel
anime earth92131 is where the 90s
animated shows of both x-men
and spider-man come in and earth 65 is
the universal id for spider-gwen it's
the universe where gwen stacy gets
bitten by the radioactive spider instead
of peter parker and goes on to become
spider woman while peter parker turns
himself into the lizard in an attempt to
be special like her and yes this is the
same gwen stacy who gets pulled through
a portal to be a part of into the
spider-verse which itself takes place in
earth 1610
and now you can see first off how
confusing this gets but also
how these things are starting to come
together now in the official handbook of
the marvel universe a to z
the mcu was given the designation of one
nine nine
nine nine nine apparently named after
the year kevin feige started producing
the x-men movie
plus just some more nines in there to
sound cool however
with avengers end game the mcu is now
canonically not taking place in a single
universe anymore as discussed by hulk in
the ancient one the infinity stones
create what you experience as the flow
of time
remove one of the stones and that close
splits
now this may benefit your reality but my
new one
not so much wait hold on here quick
sidebar in the movie thanos admits to
destroying the infinity stones the
things that we just heard
create the flow of time talk about your
lines that no one remembered that they
had included in the script anyway as
that scene proves
at the very least we've witnessed
multiple different realities in the mcu
on the big screen that's how we get
ourselves a dead loki in the main
mcu but a very much alive loki in the
upcoming loki solo series on disney plus
agents of shield is also canonized to be
taking place in the mcu it's been
churning out different timelines
at an alarming pace in season 5 the
agents of shield are sent through a time
monolith which is like a gooey poor
man's time stone to a reality in which
earth was destroyed at the same time as
thanos
attacked by a completely unrelated event
involving the villain
graviton resulting in the near
extinction of all humanity so they go
back in time with the monolith stopping
him and creating
a second major mcu-related timeline
since then they've been going gung-ho
with time travel because
i can't believe i'm even gonna try to
explain this plot but here we go
an alien civilization of super
intelligent computers lose their home
world so they kidnap the shield
scientists they believe solve time
travel and ask them to build a new time
travel machine so that they can save
their home planet in the past they
somehow managed to build it which the
aliens then used to go back in time to
stop
shield from being made so they could
invade earth more easily which actually
works but the shield scientists managed
to take all the main characters back to
a good timeline sacrificing the one in
which season seven takes place
season seven is hilarious by the way and
i'm at least
sixty percent sure that the writers are
in on the joke in any case
agents of shield has taken place in no
fewer than three distinct timelines
again connected canonically via the mcu
so the mcu is in and of itself a
multiverse
you're saying there's a multiverse also
while i'm thinking about it who needs a
time stone or for that matter who needs
to beg tony stark to invent time travel
when your shield pals already had
themselves a time machine
just saying captain america if you had
just paid a bit more attention to the
little guys in your canonically related
tv spin-off series you would have saved
yourself a lot of trouble
okay so why am i talking about all this
well it seems that the next big step for
the mcu will be combining
all the different multiverses into one
from the movies of course but also from
the tv shows
and also from the comics in 2015 marvel
destroyed the comics multiverse in their
second secret wars event
long story short this plot line had
earths from different universes
colliding destroying their
entire universe in the process in an
unusual turn of events the heroes
ultimately fail to save the multiverse
pieces of different universes got
smashed together in an
area beyond time and space called battle
world before things were eventually
reset into the eighth
and current iteration but here's the
thing marvel used this massive event not
only to reset but to massively
rework the marvel continuity they took
the chance to end the ultimate line of
comics but moved popular characters like
miles morales
over into the main 616 continuity the
event helped
clean up marvel history while not
totally rewriting
all of the characters the idea was that
new readers wouldn't have to know the
entire history of the marvel universe
just to get into a new book but
long time readers didn't have to abandon
everything that they knew and loved
about their all-time favorites and
there's certainly some hints that the
mcu is setting up the pieces now for a
multiverse ending event of its own
remember marvel through the next few
phases needs to find a way to top end
game
the most ambitious crossover in history
where all the greatest heroes in the
universe collide
so how do you do that by making all the
greatest heroes in the multiverse
collide or to quote anthony russo
talking about the next avengers quote it
would be the biggest movie you could
possibly
imagine so that's what really excites us
about the story the ambition of it
is even bigger than the ambition of the
infinity saga before i completely write
that off as insane remember
into the spider-verse introduce the
world to the idea of not just a
multiversal superhero movie but a
multiverse where characters could
operate by
wildly different rules and based on its
box office and critical success you can
bet marvel is looking to crib some notes
from that movie
the latest rumors burning up the
internet all seem to indicate that toby
maguire from the 2000s era spider-man
trilogy and
andrew garfield of the amazing
spider-man movies are both going to
appear as alternate universe spideys in
the next
mcu spider-man outing these casting
decisions are still definitely rumors
but when asked directly about them they
simply stated that quote those rumored
castings were not confirmed makes it
sound a lot less like it's not happening
and more like they're still in contract
negotiations
in addition you have agents of shield
outright creating teams of secret
warriors preparing for some secret war
of their own
some battles need to be fought with
secret warriors i understand the need
for these secret warriors but it's the
thor
comics that seem to most hinted what's
coming in both of the latest two thor
stories thor has been worried about the
end
of his universe in the comic king thor a
future thor from earth11412 worries
about the coming
all black which is the end of his
universe in the form of gore the god
butcher
and his necro sword to quote from that
series but now the universe is a
trembling
invalid collapsing it upon itself and
wheezing
its last soon there will only be entropy
an inert sea of all consuming
nothingness
these are but life's final twitches
behold the dying of the light
what's more the newest mainline thor
comics have focused around a similar
malicious force the black winter
the star plague the great black winter
it is coming
yeah it's winter coming for you thor
don't worry if history proves true
it's not as bad as they make it out to
be or is it you see the black winter is
the maximum escalation of bad guy
as the silver surfer puts it quote the
black winter killed the universe before
ours thor as galactus devours worlds the
winter comes for realities
just to showcase exactly how much of a
bad guy the black winter really
is they showed him literally destroying
the dc
universe which gotta admit is just some
top tier trolling
it's revealed that the black winter has
destroyed the entire multiverse before
causing the end of the sixth incarnation
of the universe he is such a bad dude
that even galactus who was the sole
survivor
of the last multiverse is afraid of him
galactus claims that to him
the black winter looks like thor and
wouldn't you know it but in the king
thor comic we learn that thor
might actually be the one to cause the
end of the universe as they say there
all hail thor the end father even the
black winter himself calls thor
the end god but to me one of the most
interesting bits from the comics is this
line
also from that recently released king
thor as the universe prepares for
collapse
do you remember how this whole saga
began jane foster
the man gog the war of the realms the
cosmic
god cop cases jane foster for those who
don't remember is natalie portman's
character from the first two thor movies
and ever so briefly an
endgame when phase four was announced at
last year's comic con natalie portman
took the stage and triumphantly hoisted
mjolnir above her head
clearly signaling the coming of jane
foster's
thor in the upcoming thor love and
thunder so
that's one pretty solidly off that
checklist the war of the realms
also kinda happened in the mcu during
the events of thor
ii i bet you forgot about this one the
war of the realms is
actually a comic plot that came in the
immediate aftermath of thor 2 but dealt
with similar issues as that movie such
as malakath's attempt to destroy
everything so that is too off of that
bucket list before the end of the
universe
the cosmic god cop cases haven't
happened yet but it's
likely the loki series will actually
deal with these you see god cops
are exactly what it sounds like they are
a police force for gods
let's not get much deeper than that
which honestly sounds like the sort of
thing that would fit
really well in a show about a renegade
god loki
on the loose messing with moments
throughout history
which is exactly how that disney plus
loki series is being described and then
finally there's mangog a villain that's
not really worth explaining in detail
here but was trapped beneath asgard in
the comics so he's probably
still safely contained under the
so there's a good chance that mangog is
out there on the loose and that we'll be
seeing him soon
giving us a four for four on the
checklist before the end of days
comes to the marvel multiverse the long
and short of it all is this
the comics are already setting up for
another multiversal end
they've introduced black winter a threat
that's destroyed the multiverse before
and it's starting to threaten marvel's
biggest heroes
on its own this would normally be the
start of a huge comic crossover event
but
given the recent events at marvel i
think it's actually setting up for
something
even bigger i know i'm not comic book
theory but i think there's a lot of
hints that kevin feige wants us to see
or ideas that he wants to test out
before they hit the big screen
in his short tenure as cco he's already
had
thor tackle the end of the universe
multiple
times in the comics and consider this
marvel studios
is acting more like a comics company
today than it ever has
they have movies they have disney plus
spin-offs they have animated spin-offs
heck
thor even crossed over into fortnite in
a canonical tie-in
and no that is not just a theory
according to marvel comics editor mark
basso quote we had a lot of great
creative discussions between marvel and
epic games about where our story lines
would cross over naturally
and seeing how prima target the fortnite
island would be for galactus who donnie
cates has already been exploring in his
thor
series set the whole thing in motion
just like with the comics some
characters
some storylines will stick around and
some won't but after the next few phases
you'll need a way
to bring it all back together to keep
the characters that work to lose the
ones that don't all
into one timeline that the average
moviegoer can still
watch and appreciate and that is why i
think a multiversal threat
and ultimate collapse is on the horizon
just like thanos was all throughout the
infinity saga
not this phase not the next but just
like with thanos this will be the next
big arc
collapsing the universes and it all
begins
with thor but hey that's just
a theory a film theory and
cuts
[Music]
you